one of the strangest but also most
intriguing and redemptive things that
humans get up to in almost any culture
one cares to study is occasionally to
gather in large groups bathe in the
rhythmic sounds of drums and flutes
organs and guitars chants and cries and
move their arms and legs about in a
complicated and frenzied way losing
themselves in the bewilderment of a
dance dancing has a claim to be
considered among the most essential and
salutary activities we ever partake in
not for nothing did Friedrich Nietzsche
a painfully inhibited figure in day to
day life declare I would believe only in
a God who could dance a comment that
stands beside his equally apodictic
pronouncement without music life would
be a mistake but dancing is at the same
time an activity that many of us
arguably those of us who might most need
to do it are powerfully inclined to
resist and deep down to fear we stand on
the side of the dance floor appalled at
the possibility of being called to join
in we attempt to make our excuses the
moment the music begins we take pains
that no one will ever ever see our hips
unite with a beat the point here is
definitely not to learn to dance like an
expert it is to remember that dancing
badly is something we might actually
want to do and equally importantly
something that we already well know how
to do at least to the level of appalling
proficiency we need to possess in order
to derive key benefits in almost all
cultures and at all points of history
except oddly enough perhaps our own
dancing has been widely and publicly
understood as a form of bodily exercise
with something very important to
contribute to our mental state dancing
has had nothing to do with dancing well
being young or revealing one stylishness
summed up sharply we might put it like
this dancing has been valued for
allowing us to transcend our
individuality and for inducing us to
merge
into a larger more welcoming and more
redemptive hole the ancient Greeks were
for the most part committed worshippers
of the rational mind therefore most God
Apollo was the embodiment of cool reason
and disciplined wisdom however the
Greeks understood with prescient that a
life devoted only to the serenity of the
mind could be at grave risk of
desiccation and loneliness and so they
balance their concern with Apollo with
regular festivals in honor of a quite
different god Dionysus a God that drank
wine stayed up late loved music and
danced the Greeks knew that the more
rational usually are the more important
it is at points to fling ourselves
around to the wild rhythms of pipes and
drums at the festivals of Dionysus held
in Athens in March every year even the
most venerable and dignified members of
the community would join into
unrestrained dancing that irrigated by
generous amounts of red wine lasted
until dawn a word often used to describe
such dancing is ecstatic
it's a telling term ecstatic comes from
two Latin words ex meaning apart and
stasis meaning standing indicating a
state in which we are symbolically
standing apart from ourselves that is
separated from the dense detailed and
self-centered layers of our identities
which we normally focus on and obsess
over and reconnected with something more
primal and more necessary our common
human nature we remember through a
period of ecstatic dancing what it's
like to belong to be part of something
larger than ourselves to be indifferent
to our own egos to be reunited with
humanity this aspiration hasn't entirely
disappeared in modernity but it's been
assigned to very particular and woefully
selective ambassadors the disco and the
rave these associations point us in
unhelpful directions towards being cool
a certain age wearing particular clothes
liking a certain
have often rather arduous music such
markers of an elite knowing crowd
reinforced rather than dismantle our
tendencies towards isolation and
loneliness so we need urgently to
recover a sense of the universal benefit
an impact of dancing but the greatest
enemy of this is fear and in particular
the fear as we may put it that we will
look like an idiot in front of people
whose opinion might matter the way
through this is not to be told that we
will in fact appear really rather fine
and with a bit of effort very far from
idiotic quite the opposite we should
accept with good grace that the whole
point of redemptive consoling cathartic
communal dancing is a chance to look
like a total thoroughgoing idiot the
bigger the better
in the company of hundreds of other
equally and generously publicly idiotic
fellow humans we spend a good deal of
our time fearing as if it were a
momentous calamity that we didn't even
dare to contemplate in daylight that we
might be idiots and holding back from a
host of important aspirations and
ambitions as a result we should shake
ourselves from such inhibitions by
loosening a hold on any remaining sense
of dignity and by accepting frankly that
we are by nature of course completely
idiotic
greates sacks of foolishness that cry in
the night bump into doors fart in the
bath and kiss people's noses by mistake
but far from being shameful and
isolating this idiocy is in fact a basic
feature of our nature that unites us
immediately with everyone else on the
planet we are idiots now we were idiots
then and we will be idiots again in the
future there is no other option for a
human to be dancing provides us with a
primordial occasion on which this basic
idiocy can be publicly displayed and
communally celebrated on a dance floor
filled with comparable idiots we can at
last delight in our joint foolishness we
can throw off our customary shyness and
reserved and fully embrace our dazzling
strangeness and arrangement an hour of
frantic jigging should
sigh Sibley shakers from any enduring
belief in our normalcy or seriousness
whenever we have the chance to invite
other people around especially very
serious people by whom were intimidated
or whom we might be seeking to impress
we should remember the divine Dionysus
and dare with his wisdom in mind to put
on dancing queen
I'm so excited or we are family knowing
that we have nature on side we should
let rip with a playlist that includes
what a feeling
dance with somebody and Hey Jude we
should lose command of our normal
rational pilot selves abandon our arms
to the harmonies throw away our belief
in a right way to dance build the
intensities of our movements to a frenzy
and merge with the universe or at least
it's more immediate representatives our
fellow new mad friends before whom the
disclosure of idiocy will be total
through a dance we glimpse a huge
project how we might more regularly
experience ourselves as vulnerable in
front of other people in order to become
better friends to ourselves and more
generous and compassionate companions to
others the true potential of dancing has
for too long been abandoned by
thoughtful people just stylish
ambassadors who have forgotten the
elemental seriousness of allowing
themselves to be and to look idiotic we
should reclaim the ecstatic dance an
uninhibited boogie-woogie for that
deepest universal purposes to reconnect
reassure and reunite us
our online shop has a range of books and
gifts that address the most important
and often neglected areas of life click
now to learn more
you